Speaker 1: . David, is it possible that running
Trump in twenty, twenty four could actually
be a disaster for the Republican Party?
Yeah, I mean, listen, if they lose, it's bad.
A lot of this stuff is figured out in retrospect,
if if Trump runs in twenty four and loses,
then yeah, it's bad if Trump runs in twenty
four and wins then it's good by definition
because they won.
But I think that the better lens through which
we should view it is even Republicans who
don't like Trump.
Agree that having Trump for four years was
better than having Hillary, and when you understand
that, you get a sense of the reality that
even if I mean, listen, Trump 2016 was a disaster
for the Republican Party.
Trump won.
They lost the House in twenty eighteen.
They lost the Senate in twenty twenty.
They lost the White House in twenty, twenty,
twenty, twenty two to be determined how they
do so.
It was a disaster to run Trump.
And yet the Republican Party is still mostly
united.
They're overwhelmingly behind Donald Trump.
Two thirds of them say they would follow Donald
Trump to a third party if that's what it came
down to in order to keep supporting Donald
Trump.
So there's a reason that the Republican Party
continues to embrace him.
Big picture, despite the fact that he lost
everything for them.
And it's become really, really clear over
the last five years, 10 years, even really
starting with the Bush era, although during
the Obama phase, it really kicked up.
Republicans have given up on policy and you
know, oh, we're about fiscal conservatism
now.
They criticized the budget as a political
cudgel.
They use it as a cudgel.
But then when their guy blows up the budget,
they don't say a word about it.
They say support the troops, except when they
don't.
And they say support the police, except when
they don't.
All of this stuff is bogus.
They've given up on policy.
Given that now the Republican Party has decided
that they're basically going to be a, you
know, meme and own the left type party focused
on talking about communism and socialism in
this type of thing.
In a sense, Trump's a good candidate for that
because Trump no one brought in people who
don't care about policy and never did and
weren't engaged in politics.
And for the first time, they paid attention
because they like the idea of how Trump talked
and the fact that it wasn't about policy.
It was just about meaning, essentially trolling
in some sense.
And even establishment Republicans who may
not like that realize, well, if it's Trump
or Hillary, 99 percent of us still prefer
Donald Trump.
So when we say could twenty twenty four be
a disaster for the Republican Party, it could
be bad for them and that they might lose and
they might lose really, really bad like they
did in twenty, eighteen and twenty twenty.
But as far as fracturing and destroying the
Republican Party, if anything has been proven
over the last four months, I guess, or, you
know, six since the election or.
Wait, how many has it been.
No, it's been eight months since the election.
That's crazy.
If anything has been proven, it's that even
when they lose, Republicans still seem very
united, that even a mediocre candidate, as
they may see Trump, some of them is better
than Hillary, it's better than Joe Biden.
And so from that standpoint, I don't think
it will be terrible for Republicans to run
Trump in twenty twenty four.
And you know what?
If he loses, they'll be energized again, the
way many of them are energized right now.
If you disagree with me, send me your thoughts.
Also, make sure that you are signed up.
Join Pakman Dotcom so that you get access
to the bonus show on which today we will be
discussing many exciting and important stories
Unidentified: we will see about.